In general, the transfer of data between Twinmotion and Unreal is rather straightforward, but in some cases, you may encounter some glitches that require your attention.
This is the case with the planters on the roof. Their LOD settings are quite aggressive.
You'll also note that these planters are supposed to be identical and yet are using different static meshes for reference.
Select the first planter using the Boxum static mesh reference.
Open that reference in the static mesh editor by double-clicking its thumbnail.
Check the four existing LODs. Only the first two make sense.
This is a low poly model we can do with just two LODs. Set the number of LODs to 2 and apply the changes.
Save the updates and exit the static mesh editor.
Select all the planters and assign them to use the Boxum static mesh we just updated.
Now they look better, even from afar.
Similarly, you can make quick adjustments to collisions.
As mentioned, collisions are not carried over using Datasmith Interop.
You can test this by going into play mode and see that you can walk through walls.
Fortunately with architectural scenes, walls are often made of simple geometry and usually have a low poly count.
This means that you can in fact use their geometry to detect collisions.
To do it in bulk, you can filter all wall objects in the Outliner and press Enter to select them.
You can then right-click any of them and then use Browse to Asset.
The associated assets are now selected in the Content Browser.
Right-click on one of them and then choose Asset Actions, Edit Selection in Property Matrix.
A dialog appears in the search box type Collision and then change the Collision Complexity to Use Complex Collision as Simple.
For practice, do the same with the Curtain Panels actors to be able to collide with the curtain walls.
Remember this method is only effective with simple geometry.
With complex geometry, you would want to assign simple collision shells.
Of course, your motion is now restricted inside the main building.
In Twinmotion, the doors are made to open when you get close to them, but this effect has not made the transition to Unreal Engine.
In the next step, you replace the doors using a blueprint.